et la ministre russe du développement
économique de passage à paris appelle au
calme et à la concertation afin que
l'économie notamment françaises et
russes profite aux deux parties
toute sanction toutes ces conversations
toujours un impact négatif
tu nous mets l'économie russe et une
économie très puissante et très stable
et au cours de ces dernières années la
russie a pris à se développer nous avons
créé des secteurs qui n'existait pas
auparavant
par exemple nous avons fortement
développé notre agriculture notre
industrie agroalimentaire et les
entreprises françaises y ont également
participé
et elles en ont également bénéficié
d'une certaine façon par conséquent
aucune sanction ne peut limiter
l'économie russe nous avons besoin d'un
dialogue normal calme et de confiance
c'est bien là dessus que notre président
assiste toujours et propose toujours de
manière active et nous sommes prêts à
tous les niveaux au niveau des
entreprises au niveau gouvernemental au
niveau ministériel a travaillé
activement et à expliquer notre position
le plus important est qu en menant un
dialogue nous pouvons toujours trouver
une solution à tous les problèmes même
les plus compliqués